[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au menu de l'actualité et des
infopratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce mardi 28 mars
10e journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites dans le cortège
parisien qui a réuni 450 000
manifestants selon ces syndicats et des
militants yvelinois venus à bord d'une
dizaine de bus parties du département et
la grève et ses conséquences notamment
dans les stations essence dont beaucoup
se retrouvent à sec en raison du blocage
des raffineries le point dans cette
édition c'est ce samedi le réseau des
médiathèques de 50 ans en Yvelines des
cernes ses prix du livre une journée
festive se tient à l'occasion au Théâtre
national et à la médiathèque du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le prix les
visionnaires récompense trois romans
évoquants des questions du monde de
demain la sélection du livre est lire et
choisir elle et choisir a été choisie
justement par des élèves de 5e de
l'agglomération le président du jury des
prix du livre de 50 ans en Yvelines
Daniel Picouly et notre invité
et puis bien qu'il est décédé en 2017
Johnny Hallyday est encore vivant dans
tous les cœurs et les cœurs de millions
de fans un voisin le Bretonneux une
exposition en hommage à l'idole des
jeunes c'est jusqu'à dimanche à la
maison de Coville le fun club officiel
du chanteur en partenariat avec la Ville
propose 50 clichés immortalisés par
Patrick dewin lors de sa tournée en 2012
le prix du livre de 50 ans en Yvelines
et l'expo Johnny Hallyday au menu de
notre page culturelle tout à l'heure
dans le 7 8 il y aura aussi des invités
un duo musical qui est venu du
sud-yvelines et qui fait de la chanson
française leur nom c'est les mineurs et
les composés composés de Bastien Ragot
bonsoir bonsoir et de Simon bolsinget
bonsoir alors vous êtes avec nous en
quelques mots déjà Bastien l'univers des
mineurs qu'est-ce que c'est un duo de
chanson française inspiré par des
groupes comme Debout sur le Zinc volo on
compose on écrit des chansons
humoristiques engagés poétiques et à
base de violoncelle contrebasse guitare
et sur fond de pédales de loop alors on
en parlera peut-être un peu plus un peu
plus tard précisément de ce que c'est et
même pourquoi pas il y a des trois
petites annonces aussi pour après donc
vous êtes chanteuse
guitariste trompettiste vous Simon vous
êtes chanteur violoncelliste contre
bassiste et guitariste on l'a compris
Bastien commençant en parler mais les
mineurs c'est aussi la part belle aux
instruments oui ben tout ça c'est
l'esprit acoustique vraiment présent
dans notre façon de de jouer parce qu'on
vient tous les deux du classique donc de
l'acoustique vraiment du son du son
acoustique des instruments et c'est vrai
qu'on avait envie de garder cette
vraiment cette grosse influence
acoustique dans nos compositions et
faire sauter tous ces instruments là
ensemble voilà donc on va apprendre à
mieux vous connaître dans un instant on
parlera aussi de votre actualité vos
projets à venir sur la scène musicale il
va y avoir aussi du sport au menu de
cette édition de la sueur de l'effort au
menu et de la diagonale 78 ou la diag 78
appelé là comme vous voulez la quatrième
édition c'est ce samedi et 1er avril et
parmi les épreuves proposées il y a ce
trail de
kilomètres qui va traverser les Yvelines
de breuilboire Aubert à
Rochefort-en-Yvelines on en parlera tout
à l'heure avec nos invités il y aura
Alain pelos notamment en organisateur de
la direction 78 a participé aussi qui
est maire de Villepreux Jean-Baptiste
amoni qu'on aura l'occasion d'en parler
avec eux dans un instant également à mes
côtés Régine rage de la rédaction tv78
bonsoir Régine on va faire le point avec
vous dans un instant sur l'actualité à
retenir de ce mardi dans les Yvelines à
suivre également à l'épisode 2 de nos
reportages consacrés aux Journées
Européennes des Métiers d'Art c'est
jusqu'à dimanche rencontre ce soir avec
les artisans du chantier de l'église de
Sartrouville et puis comme chaque mardi
les insolites de Véronique turbit ces
informations originales qui vous ont
peut-être échappé dans les Yvelines
voici le programme avant de le dérouler
on va jeter un petit coup d'œil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
un ciel voilé également demain dans les
Yvelines pendant toute la journée côté
température dans la matinée elle s'est
similaire à aujourd'hui il fera 9 degrés
dans toutes les Yvelines dans
l'après-midi en revanche c'est beaucoup
plus printanier voire estivale 19 degrés
sont attendus sur la moitié nord du
département il devrait faire à 18 degrés
au sud aux alentours de Rambouillet ce
mercredi 29 mars c'est la sainte Gladys
on fait le point tout de suite sur
l'actualité du jour dans les Yvelines
et on commence les actualités Régine par
cette information la dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites c'était au programme ce mardi
oui elle est magnifiquement été nombreux
à se mobiliser dans les Yvelines une
dizaine de garçons partis direction
Paris et ils se sont donnés rendez-vous
place de la République à 14h quelles ont
été les perturbations engendrées par la
grève alors du côté des raffineries on
compte 16% des stations essence en
difficulté à l'échelle nationale et par
difficulté j'entends rupture totale ou
rupture partielle et quant au
département des Yvelines il fait partie
des départements les plus touchés
puisque
33,6% des stations services sont presque
à sec difficile donc de se
réapprovisionner en carburant on écoute
tout de suite les réactions au micro de
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude c'est assez
difficile d'en trouver au quotidien on
sait jamais d'une station à l'autre si
on va en avoir c'est toujours le petit
stress de dire faut quand même anticiper
on anticipe aujourd'hui le plan de sens
là ça fait quelques jours ça commence à
être compliqué
à 3 4e
donc je fais le plein pour aller
travailler pour déposer les enfants à
l'école à la crèche donc oui j'ai besoin
de la voiture on peut pas faire
autrement en fait et puis il y a
quasiment 2 euros le litre personne ne
va à la station-service par plaisir je
suis pas embêté mais j'ai une vraie
pensée pour les gens qui sont qui sont
embêtés et qui se battent aussi pour
leurs droits donc je suis plutôt
solidaire
et enfin côté transport c'était aussi
très compliqué aujourd'hui il fallait
prévoir par exemple un train sur deux
pour les lignes A B et n un train sur 3
pour la ligne C et deux trains sur 3
pour les lignes JL et U nouvelle
perturbations annoncées demain pour
rester informé bien sûr le
www.transilien.com pour avoir
l'actualité trafic du côté de
l'éducation qu'elles ont été les
perturbations perturbations du jour
alors du côté des écoles primaires
d'après les syndicats le département
comptait 188 classes fermées aujourd'hui
et du côté des facultés plusieurs sites
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ont fermé ce
jour pour permettre aux étudiants
d'aller manifester sur Paris aujourd'hui
dans l'actualité du jour également
Régine cet accident qui a eu lieu ce
matin à Poissy oui un petit garçon âgé
de 3 ans est tombé du quatrième étage
d'un immeuble rue Saint-Sébastien
d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquête l'enfant se trouvait seul dans
le logement au moment de la chute il a
été transporté à l'hôpital Necker à
Paris et pronostic vital n'est pas
engagé information du jour également
côté économie avec l'enseigne de
restauration Courtepaille qui connaît
des difficultés effectivement la chaîne
de restauration Courtepaille à
solliciter ce lundi 27 mars une
procédure de redressement judiciaire
auprès du tribunal de commerce de
Nanterre l'enseigne a d'abord connu des
difficultés financières pendant la crise
sanitaire et la situation s'est aggravée
notamment avec la flambée de l'invasion
de l'inflation alors pour rappel le
Groupe compte six restaurants dans les
Yvelines à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
Flins-sur-Seine Louveciennes
mandebuchelay Orgeval et Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines on passe à notre image du
jour un peu plus positive elle devrait
donner fin je pense à noter les
spectateurs et cette image du jour ce
sont des croissants les sélections
régionales d'Île-de-France pour le 18e
concours du meilleur croissant au beurre
d'Isigny avait lieu ce mardi 28 mars au
lycée hôtelier à Guyancourt alors il y
avait 10 élèves qui représentaient cinq
établissements franciliens et parmi
critères de sélection il y avait
l'aspect la qualité du feuilletage ou
encore le goût la première place du
concours revient donc à Lina Meziane je
vous propose d'écouter les propos
recueillis par Julien Leroy alors le
l'objectif du concours c'est de mettre
en valeur les produits régionaux tels
que le bird Isigny et puis le travail de
nos élèves et de nos apprentis qui
doivent réaliser 24 croissants courbés
pur beurre c'est une belle expérience ça
permet d'entrer dans le monde des
concours et ça nous montre aussi la
discipline à avoir et même
professionnellement parlant ça je pense
à nous fait grandir aussi dans le côté
et la finale aura lieu au mois de mai
prochain dans la ville de Caen les
finalistes devront préparer des
viennoiseries créatives et on leur
souhaite bonne chance Bastien Simon j'ai
senti de l'intérêt sur les images de
croissance
du dîner du soir ça donne effectivement
enfin au goûter voilà le goûter on l'a
peut-être pas forcément pris on termine
ces informations du jour et qu'une
information insolite à
Fontenay-le-Fleury tout à fait jouer
sans s'arrêter du lever jusqu'au coucher
du soleil c'était l'objectif du FC
Fontenay-le-Fleury dimanche dernier le
club amateur de football a organisé un
match de l'environnement et pendant 12
heures près de 220 joueurs se sont
succédés sur le terrain du stade
Descartes le but de cette journée de
sensibiliser aux enjeux environnementaux
et donc en marge de l'événement il y
avait plusieurs ateliers comme un
atelier sur le traitement des eaux
usés ou encore sur les bonnes pratiques
en matière de sobriété énergétique bravo
pour cette initiative en 12 heures de
match c'est quand même une sacrée
performance du côté de Fleury merci
Régine pour ces informations et si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'une actualité d'un fait qui vous fait
réagir dans l'actualité n'hésitez pas à
le dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news dans cette
actualité du jour vous l'aurez compris
ce contexte tendu autour de la réforme
des retraites et nous vous en parlions
hier des élus ont été visés dans ce
contexte de tension dégradation de
permanence parlementaire ou encore
menaces dans les Yvelines au moins à
trois députés ont reçu récemment des
lettres de menaces et d'insultes c'est
le cas de Marie le bec député de la
quatrième circonscription qui a porté
plainte son témoignage
[Musique]
oui c'est un contexte qu'on retrouve
qu'on avait déjà connu par le passé à
l'occasion notamment du mouvement des
gilets jaunes notamment donc on sait
qu'on peut malheureusement être victime
de ce genre de menace là effectivement
je vois que avec le contexte de la
réforme de retraite moi mes collègues
certains sont menacés donc d'autres ont
leur permanence dégradées donc c'est à
la fois un contexte qu'on connaît et
qu'on développe en même temps
[Musique]
c'est toujours assez effrayant de voir
que quelqu'un est capable d'écrire des
propos pareil effectivement qui aussi
vise nos proches nos familles parce que
on ne souhaite pas ça pour nos proches
et un engagement qui doit rester un
engagement politique on peut avoir des
points de désaccord ils peuvent être
forts aussi mais je crois que voilà il
faut respecter le fait que c'est un
combat politique et pas un combat de
personnes mais pour autant moi je
continue sereinement mon action sur le
terrain auprès avec mon équipe auprès de
mes militants sans inquiétude
particulière
[Musique]
c'est assez ridicule de penser que j'ai
à ce point du temps à perdre pour faire
moi-même un courrier de menaces et ma
collègueur robergé aussi enfin
honnêtement j'ai trouvé ça assez
ridicule assez pathétique et je pense
que ça doit aussi rappeler à tous ceux
qui ont du mal à condamner la violence
du mal à
s'exprimer sur le sujet que quand on a
une espèce d'appel à la révolte ou à
l'insoumission permanente c'est aussi ce
à quoi nous on est exposé en tant que en
tant qu'élu
absolument j'ai porté plainte ce qui est
à la fois c'est important parce que en
fait on constate que beaucoup de mes
collègues reçoivent des lettres un peu
similaires il y a le Groupe Berger qui
était donc cité dans mon courrier et que
je me suis permis de lui transmettre
pour qu'elle soit au fait qu'elle était
aussi elle-même cité dans ma plainte
c'est important de rappeler que voilà
on doit rester dans un contexte de
dialogue et de et de débat et puis aussi
parce que ça mettrait un terme à toutes
ces lettres et courrier qui sont
extrêmement désagréables
Jean-Baptiste amonic était avec nous en
plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
participé dans quelques jours à la diag
78 c'est ce pourquoi vous êtes venus ce
soir dans le 7 8 juste avant d'en parler
une question à l’élus que vous êtes
aussi maire de Villepreux vice-président
de 50 ans en Yvelines et président du
MoDem 78 quel regard portez-vous sur ce
climat tendu actuellement autour de la
réforme des retraites des députés
notamment qui se retrouvent menacées
c'est le cas de Marie le bec que l'on
vient d'entendre oui vous venez d'avoir
un exemple avec Marie le bec mais j'ai
aussi une pensée pour Aurore berger qui
a été victime comme d'autres élus de ce
type de lettre de menaces avec toujours
je trouve une escalade dans les propos
et la violence des des invinves que ces
élus peuvent recevoir là j'ai vu que
c'était même son enfant qui était pris
qui était pris en charge par par les
auteurs de de ces lettres moi évidemment
je les condamne et je pense qu'il faut
les condamner quel que soit l'élu quel
que soit son camp et son bord politique
moi je suis très in par ça je l'avais
perçu quand je travaillais à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quelques temps déjà
pour le moment on semble être un petit
peu préservé au niveau de l'échange
local mais je suis très préoccupé par
par ces lettres il faut appeler
aujourd'hui à l'apaisement est-ce que
c'est possible aujourd'hui un apaisement
dans ce climat tendu et il va falloir il
va falloir que ce soit possible après je
pense que on se pose tous la question
aujourd'hui en tant que responsable
politique comment on peut participer à
cette apaisement malheureusement on n'a
pas de baguette magique mais on y œuvre
on y œuvre et je crois qu'il faut
rappeler aujourd'hui que les élus sont
là justement dans l'intérêt général et
que se prendra eux c'est aussi sans
prendre à nos institutions et donc à
notre République alors dans un instant
un tout autre sujet on va parler avec
vous de la diag 78 notamment à trail de
100 km qui va traverser les Yvelines il
y a plusieurs courses au programme il y
aura un peu l'eau sur l'organisateur de
l'événement qui sera avec nous dans un
instant pour en parler à vos côtés
précis jusqu'à Laurent Pallot bonsoir et
vous êtes vous gérant d'endurance shop
cette boutique à Bois-d'Arcy qui est
partenaire de cet événement on va
revenir avec vous à plus largement sur
cette édition de diag 78 mais avant
toute cette semaine TV 78 mais en
lumière à l'artisanat c'était l'occasion
des Journées européennes des métiers
d'art sont clocher menacés de
s'effondrer c'est pourquoi d'importants
travaux ont été lancés à l'église
Saint-Martin de Sartrouville la flèche a
été entièrement démontée et en cours de
reconstruction ainsi est différents
corps de métiers
œuvres à la sauvegarde de l'édifice
millénaire une rencontre signée Julien
Laurent on appelle ça une crête de coq
c'est pour faire étanchéité entre les
deux faîtières et du coup c'est le petit
côté artistique sur ce chantier de
l'église Saint-Martin de Sartrouville
Julien Sartori peaufine les derniers
détails ce mercredi 15 mars l'équipe
couverture s'affaire pour achever
l'arrière de la toiture de cet édifice
classé au Monument Historique là on
vient de finir l'abside je suis en train
de faire les crêpes de coq là pour finir
étanchéité du faîtage on essaye vraiment
de travailler à l'ancienne tout en
essayant d'améliorer pour éviter les
risques de fuite édifiant 1009 sur une
butte dominance Sartrouville cette
église emblématique de la commune a
débuté plus importants travaux en
janvier 2022 suite à de nombreuses
fissures et déformations la stabilité du
clocher n'était plus assurée une
reconstruction était nécessaire nous
avons d'abord procédé au démontage de la
de la flèche et puis en partant du haut
d'abord le coq puis en redescendant
pierre par pierre en les notant on les
en les mesurant de façon à les
reproduire à l'identique avec une pierre
identique également qui provient d'une
carrière de Saint-Maximin à une
quinzaine de mètres du sol ce sculpteur
réalise les ornements sur le clocher de
l'église grâce à ce modèle en plâtre il
va tailler dans la roche la statue de ce
lion réalisée en hommage au futur roi de
France pendant la guerre de Cent ans
Charles V a fait démonter ce que cette
flèche pour éviter que les Anglais
en prennent possession 8 ans après il a
fait remonter cette flèche et donc ils
avaient mis à cette occasion là le
blason de Charles V qui était dauphin à
cette époxy la sculpture originale ayant
disparu au moment des travaux seule une
photo du début du 20e siècle et un
document papier permettent cette
création c'est toujours la même démarche
ce n'est pas ne pas inventer c'est de
restituer au plus juste ce que les
anciens compagnons avaient réalisé à
l'époque dans le courant du mois d'avril
les trois cloches retrouveront leur
place d'origine au sein de la flèche le
vaste chantier de l'église Saint-Martin
devrait se terminer en 2024
et je vous le disais en début d'édition
il va y avoir du sport à présent dans le
7 8 on va parler de la diagonale des
Yvelines ou la diag 78 appelée là comme
vous voulez la quatrième édition de
cette compétition et programmée ce
samedi 1er avril elle proposera
différents formats pour les trailers
dans les Yvelines avec notamment un 100
km entre Breuil Bois Robert et Rochefort
en Yvelines différents invités sont avec
nous en plateau je le disais
Jean-Baptiste amonique également à
Laurent Pallot qui sont avec nous et on
a été rejoint par Alain pelos bonsoir
bonsoir et que vous êtes vous
l'organisateur justement de cette diag
78 4e édition pour cet événement qui
prend de l'ampleur on peut le dire
d'année en année on monte en puissance
pour pour cet événement oui tout à fait
puisque là on est à près de 900 coureurs
la dernière on était à 450 donc 900
coureurs cette année on est très très
content ça a bien bien fonctionné je
pense que la mayonnaise a pris je pense
que le le parcours plaît au coureur et
le concept plaît au trailer aussi donc
on est très très content et puis je
pense que ça ça avec eux ça va faire que
continuer donc vous l'avez dit beaucoup
de participantes c'est à dire que là on
va battre les précédents records là on
va être sur l'édition qui a attiré le
plus de participants tout à fait ouais
tout à fait alors c'est vrai que il y a
des petits changements qui a peut-être
permis tout ça puisque il y a le 20 km
et 12 km qui est en boucle autour de
Rochefort mais on a la preuve phares le
100 km et le 50 km qui ont pris beaucoup
on est pas loin de 150 coureurs sur le
100 km ce qui est quand même une
performance parce que tout le monde ne
court pas 100 km et on est pas loin de
300 350 sur le 50 km donc c'est on est
très très content donc différents
parcours qu'on va détailler dans un
instant on a suivi déjà plusieurs
trailers sur TV 78 certains ont décidé
par exemple de quitter les co-trails de
Paris on le suivait la semaine dernière
au départ de l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines jusqu'à la
tour Eiffel pour participer à votre
événement comment vous l'expliquer
alors comment je l'explique je pense que
le fait qu'on traverse un département le
principe de traverser la département je
pense que c'est un concept qui plaisait
et qui plaît le fait que vraiment les
Yvelines c'est un département rural
très nature on passe de différentes de
pleines de forêt de forêts d'hiver et il
y a un final qui est assez
fantastique je pense que tous ces
ingrédients font que
je pense qu'on peut attirer du monde qui
est forcément différent de du concept de
l'équatrail qui reste quand même une
course majeure mais peut-être plusieurs
ben voilà mais je fais réagir aussi les
autres invités Jean-Baptiste amonic
qu'est-ce qu'il fait à votre avis le
succès de cet événement moi je trouve
que déjà ils les ont réussi à garder un
esprit assez familial et convivial et il
y a des grands champions qui vont faire
cette course mais je trouve qu'elle est
elle est assez fédératrice et puis Alain
le disait le côté
nature qui est bien représentée dans les
différents parcours et dans les
différents tracés de cette course sans
oublier le patrimoine aussi bâti puisque
je sais plus combien de villages seront
traversés par par la course et notamment
il y a l'Association des Maires Ruraux
d'ailleurs des Yvelines qui est
partenaires et c'est pas pour rien parce
que ce sera aussi à une formidable
occasion de mettre en lumière le
patrimoine yvinois vous en pensez quoi
vous Laurent palot ce sont les mêmes
raisons qui pour vous font ce cette
renommée ce succès on est seulement à
quatre éditions on le rappelle c'est une
vraie course nature comme le disait
Jean-Baptiste et je crois que c'est le
seul ultra trail qu'on a dans le 78 donc
forcément ça va attirer du monde une
nouvelle course et ça fait du bien autre
chose que le urbain et c'est tout
naturel pour vous en tant que partenaire
d'être aux côtés d'un tel événement ah
bah on ne peut que être partenaire tel
événement dans le 78 en Jean-Baptiste
sabonique vous faites partie donc des
participants vous allez faire le 100 km
du coup vous êtes bien renseigné
après mûre réflexion je vais essayer de
faire mon premier ultra trail et donc je
me suis dit que pour le premier ultra
trail on allait le faire dans son
département dans mon département donc
dans les Yvelines j'en ai suivi aux
aventures alors à distance avec Cédric
Pembe marine le maire du Port-Marly sur
le Half Marathon des Sables engagé
justement pour l'association Messenger
cardiaque je vois que Laurent palot
porte le t-shirt vous êtes venu aussi
avec la petite mascotte de Messenger
cardiaque votre aventure avait permis
sur le Half marathon des sables de
sauver deux enfants malades du cœur vous
êtes inscrit sur on va dire sur les
mêmes objectifs c'est toujours au profit
de mes Sénat chirurgie cardiaques oui
tout à fait bah alors avec l'association
les élus du cœur qu'on a confondé avec
Cédric pembemamine mère du Port-Marly on
a clôturé toute la mobilisation de
l'année 2022 via une soirée de
remerciement la semaine passée et donc
ce sont non pas deux mais trois enfants
trois enfants qui vont être sauvés qui
vont pouvoir bénéficier d'une opération
cardiaque et donc là on se lance sur
2023 avec de nouveaux de nouveaux défis
sportifs on on en parlera mais on
repartira dans des airs en fin d'année
mais on a voulu aussi faire
différentes courses d'ailleurs pas
uniquement de la course il y aura aussi
du golf du vélo à proximité dans le
département dans la région et donc on a
eu la chance il y en a la chance d'être
partenaire aujourd'hui de la diagonale
des Yvelines on sera 25 élus du cœur à
prendre le départ la grande majorité sur
le vin km en courra au profit de mesna
chirurgicardiaque avec le maillot que
Laurent harborphyrvan et puis et puis je
remercie aussi l'organisation puisque 1
euro par dossard sera également reversé
à l'association message chirurgie
cardiaque c'est important de donner une
dimension caritative solidaire à votre
événement alors c'était c'était pas la
c'était pas l'objectif de départ mais
c'est vrai que quand Jean-Baptiste m'a
concerté à ce sujet ça devenait une
évidence et
et quand j'ai assisté la dernière fois à
la petite soirée de remise du chèque que
vous aviez récolté l'année dernière
c'est vrai que c'est une grande émotion
franchement qu'on puisse participer dans
nos moyens aider à sauver un enfant
franchement voilà c'était pas le but au
départ mais si on peut le contribuer on
est on est très content et à aventure
s'associe à ça et on est on est vraiment
très heureux et je pense que une
contribution de chacun ça fait du bien
et puis ça va apporter peut-être le
bonheur dans une famille donc c'est
génial voilà aussi Laurent Pagot
j'imagine ça aussi un cœur je vois que
vous portez ce t-shirt aussi ou
l'arborez on l'arborde parce que parce
que c'est important parce que les élus
du cœur moi j'ai rencontré Jean-Baptiste
il y a peu de temps mais au travers des
élus du cœur et pour pour son engagement
sur la course tout ça donc oui oui on
s'engage là dessus et puis et puis quand
on voit qu'une course comme ça va
pousser aussi cette belle association on
peut que être partenaire de ses courses
on va parler les quatre parcours vous
disiez alors l'idée c'est aussi d'ouvrir
à tout le monde finalement cette Ecotral
que ça s'adresse au plus grand nombre
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il y a quatre
parcours différents qui sont proposés
oui tout à fait alors nous on organise
depuis avec AES N78 plusieurs courses
depuis pratiquement 20 ans ça fait un
moment qu'on travaille là-dessus donc
les Yvelines on connaît bien tous les on
le connaît même très bien et c'est vrai
que
quand on s'est dit bon on va faire un
100 km parce que c'est à nous tenait à
cœur depuis quelques années mais c'est
quand même assez c'est une niche quand
même courir sans qu'il soit tout le
monde le Jean-Baptiste
on va parler de sa préparation dans un
instant on parlera samedi
mais donc voilà il fallait quand même
que on reste un Chalon ça reste un
challenge aussi pour d'autres coureurs
du 20 km la dernière il y avait pas de
12 cette année on a décidé de mettre un
autre parce que il y avait eu des
demandes ce sujet le bois de Rochefort
s'y prêtait aussi bien pour le 12 et
pour le 20 donc c'est ça devenait une
div de proposer quatre distances il y en
a que la dernière qui ont fait un vin
qui sont mis sur le 50 peut-être sur du
50 ils se mettra sur le sang l'année
prochaine moyenne petite évolution on
s'arrêtera là je pense je sais que
beaucoup de coureurs me disent pourquoi
pas un aller-retour
c'est du boulot quand même ça se passe
pas comment un
Ultra Trail de 100 km on vous a croisé
souvent sur des événements running dans
les Yvelines mais là c'est quand même on
va dire une plus grande distance comment
ça se prépare notamment d'ailleurs sur
ceux qui sont organisés par Alain moi je
suis tombé amoureux de la course des
flambeaux à Montfort-l'Amaury je la
trouve magnifique c'est une course
nocturne 78
on se on se prépare comme on peut dans
le peu de temps qui nous reste dans
notre quotidien professionnel donc dans
ma fonction de maire en l'occurrence je
pourrais être beaucoup plus assiduelle
entraînement ça c'est certain non mais
en ayant une bonne nutrition une bonne
hydratation on essaie de récupérer aussi
un peu de un peu de sommeil ce qui est
pas toujours chose facile voilà moi
l'objectif c'est de finir ce premier je
me donne pas d'autres objectifs ce sera
déjà très bien parce que ce sera le
premier et puis surtout remercier
l'ensemble des collègues et des amis aux
élus du cœur qui vont s'engager sur
aussi les autres distances il y en a
pour tous les niveaux c'est ce que je
trouve très bien sur cette diagonale des
Yvelines et donc que toutes ces
personnes là puisse se retrouver sur
rassembler et aller mouiller le maillot
pour et bien la bonne cause moi ça me
sent mauvais jeu de mots en tout cas ça
me fait chaud au cœur une course fort
c'est le 100 km les les difficultés sur
ce parcours qui veut en parler Laurent
est-ce que vous souhaitez en parler
est-ce qu'il y a des des difficultés
particulières à noter sur ce parcours
c'est un peu long pour ceux qui font 100
km certes il y a un peu d'eau j'ai cru
voir à certains endroits qui vont être
qui vont être sympathiques et puis la
finale je crois que Alain on a parlé au
château de Rochefort-en-Yvelines un
final en montée hein si je dis pas de
bêtises alors les 12 derniers kilomètres
il y a il y a le le bois de Rochefort
est
bien pourvu en dénivelé
non on arrivera dans la salle
polyvalente de Rochefort
monsieur Silva Lambert mère de Rochefort
nous accueille depuis 4 ans et depuis 5
ans même maintenant puisque voilà et
donc
ouais le dénivelé la fin de parcours je
pense qu'on va laisser des traces
Jean-Baptiste il faut que tu gardes un
petit peu fort et puis la difficulté
c'est que alors on nous reproche
beaucoup que on n'a pas trop de dénivelé
sur notre territoire ben voilà c'est
notre territoire on passera quand même
parler votre Cernay donc les votre
Cernay ça va laisser aussi un petit peu
de traces et puis la difficulté c'est de
courir ça peut paraître bête mais en fin
de compte c'est de tenir un rythme de à
peu près un peu en dessous de 7 km/h
pour pour les plus lents ça reste quand
même une performance sur 100 km ça reste
quand même une performance on rappelle
un départ de Breuil Bois Robert arriver
à
Rochefort-en-Yvelines dans un
département des Yvelines on l'a compris
à qui se prêtent tout à fait à ce genre
d'événements qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter une bonne météo est-ce que les
prévisions sont bonnes là pour samedi
j'ai pas pu les regarder encore ça fait
15 jours que je passe je suis sur mon
écran de matériel obligatoire il a
demandé
il y a quelques passages quelques
passages qui vont être boueux ça c'est
évident il y a des passages où on va
voir un petit peu d'eau cheville ça
c'est évident aussi la météo bah là j'ai
vu ce matin c'est plutôt plutôt correct
d'accord quelques pluies mais bon ça
devrait voilà ça je vais juger pour
l'arrivée ou pour manger la tartiflette
puisque il y aura une tartiflette à
l'arrivée voilà bon il y aura le après
l'effort le réconfort comment on dit en
tout cas merci à vous trois d'être venu
en parler en plateau et je rappelle donc
que la diag 78 sera ce samedi entre
Breuil Bois Robert et Rochefort en ligne
ça c'est pour le 100 km mais bien sûr on
l'a dit à 4 parcours qui sont proposés
vous retrouvez toutes les informations
sur le site Internet de l'événement on
va ouvrir à présent une page culture
dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et d'abord à reportage qui ravira les
fans de Johnny Hallyday 5 ans après sa
disparition l'idole des jeunes est à
l'honneur à Voisins-le-Bretonneux pas
moins de 50 clichés pris par Patrick
Deguine le photographe officiel du fan
club de Johnny Hallyday sont exposés à
la maison de Coville et ce jusqu'au 2
avril jusqu'à dimanche prochain une
exposition inaugurée et dimanche dernier
on regarde le reportage de Céline
Charles et de Michael et le midro
je t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime
que je t'aime Gabriel ou encore je te
promets ces chansons mythiques résonnent
toujours dans le coeur des nombreux fans
de Johnny Hallyday 5 ans après sa mort
son fan club officiel et la ville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux se sont associés
pour proposer aux passionnés une
exposition inédite 50 clichés capturés
par le photographe Patrick deghin sont
présentés au public à la maison de
Coville depuis 20 ans il avait cette
envie ce désir ce rêve on va dire de
d'accompagner Johnny en tournée devant
le travail qu'il a fait pendant toutes
ces années un jour il lui a dit pour la
tournée 2012 j'accepte que tu accompagne
dans cette tournée différents clichés
que j'ai fait à Los Angeles
au Stade de France
Carcassonne Brétignolles-sur-Mer je suis
surtout un passionné de Johnny il m'a
toujours intrigué en 1975 j'ai commencé
donc c'est j'ai suivi Johnny toute ma
vie quoi une bonne photo de Johnny c'est
le vrai cliché quand vous êtes de près
voyez et vous voyez Johnny qui est en
sueur et qui arrive à pouvoir sa chanson
à la chanter avec cœur ah le magnifique
franchement il y a une belle exposition
de très beaux cadres qui rappelle
beaucoup de souvenirs aussi parce que je
crois que j'ai quand même fait plus ou
moins 200 concert de Johnny un petit peu
partout un clin d'oeil à la ville que
l'icône française du rock avait déjà
visité et venez il est venu à voisins il
a tourné le film Jean-Philippe avec
Fabrice Luchini un voisin il y a presque
20 ans donc c'est un petit retour un
petit retour aux sources Harley voiture
de collection ou encore danseurs de
country était présent pour l'in
auguration de l'exposition objectif
rendre hommage à Johnny et surtout faire
perdurer son souvenir mais c'est même
pour nous une obligation un petit peu un
devoir parce que on a créé ce club il y
avait un temps avec Johnny lui-même et
moi je tiens vraiment maintenant qu'il
est parti depuis 5 ans à perpétuer cette
légende à honorer cette mémoire ça reste
et ça restera l'artiste français numéro
1 dans le cœur des Français c'est
évident tous les clichés présentés sont
proposés à la vente l'exposition se
termine le 2 avril prochain
en plateau avec de nouveau le
duodeminaire qui est revenu avec moi sur
ce plateau on va parler de vous dans
quelques instants et parler de votre
actualité lui aussi Véronique Véronique
ithurbit qui nous a rejoint bonsoir
Véronique ça va bien oui bah très bien
comme chèque mardi c'est les insolites
ce sont les insolites de Véronique ces
infos qui ont peut-être échappé à noter
les spectateurs en tout cas à vous elle
ne vous ont pas échapper elles ont
retenu votre attention donnez-vous
donnez-nous un petit avant-goût vous
allez parler de quoi aujourd'hui parler
de deux associations qui font parler
d'elle en ce moment 10 jours pour voir
autrement et une autre association qui
s'appelle vie vilaine initiative
écologique et en troisième nous avons
une bonne nouvelle pour les amoureux du
cinéma car le cinéma de Rambouillet
existe enfin comment dire il y a un
cinéma provisoire parce que celui
d'avant était fermé depuis trois ans
donc du coup une bonne nouvelle pour les
habitants de Rambouillet on va en parler
dans un instant mais d'abord on va
parler de littérature dans le 7 8 les
prix du livre de 50 ans en Yvelines vont
être remis ce samedi s'organiser par le
réseau des médiathèques de 50 ans en
Yvelines en partenariat avec marmite FM
et les librairies du pavé du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et du pavé dans
la mare à Élancourt une journée festive
se tient pour l'occasion à 50 ans en
Yvelines avec clou de l'événement la
remise des prix qui sera effectué par le
président du jury Daniel picoulis qui
est normalement connecté avec nous en
visioconférence bonsoir
normalement normalement
en tout cas vous êtes avec nous c'est
l'essentiel alors pour vous présenter
écrivain animateur de télévision vous
êtes aussi scénariste de bande dessinée
et vous allez proposer à l'occasion de
cet événement à cette remise de prix
votre one-man show pompette s'est adapté
de votre roman Les larmes du vin on va
en parler dans un instant mais j'ai une
première question pourquoi avoir accepté
d'être le président de ce prix du livre
de ses prix du livre de 50 ans en
Yvelines
d'abord parce qu'on me l'a demandé c'est
une bonne chose déjà et puis parce que
je travaille avec certains organisateurs
de salon que je connais bien en
l'occurrence Bertrand Morisset et Sarah
donc vous savez c'est un milieu on
travaille à l'amitié à la confiance on
sait que quand on va dans salon que
eux-mêmes ça se passera bien voilà donc
c'est c'est aussi ça aussi la vie
littéraire c'est des relations des
copains du coup avoir et des livres
c'est pas mal avec modération quand même
les coups à boire mais oui en tout cas
le programme
est établi aura une journée festive au
théâtre de 50 en Yvelines aussi à la
médiathèque du canal plusieurs choses
qui sont au programme on peut retrouver
d'ailleurs tout le programme détaillé
sur le site des médiathèques de 50 ans
en Yvelines le clou du spectacle c'est
la remise des prix à 17h15 et c'est une
journée mais bien deux prix qui vont
être remis Daniel Picouly avec le prix
du livre les visionnaires ça c'est le
premier
c'est le premier prix du livre de 50 ans
de vie il y a un autre prix qui
s'appelle le prix lire et choisir si
vous pouvez juste présenter ces deux
prix et quelle est la quels sont les
différences du coup entre entre ces deux
prix
le visionnaire vous voyez un petit peu
de quoi de quoi il s'agit des livres qui
se projettent dans pas seulement le
présent mais dans l'avenir et qui
essaie de nous éclairer un peu ce qu'il
en sera de notre avenir qui vous en
conviendrez c'est quelque chose de pas
très très simple aujourd'hui d'éclairer
l'avenir mais les
littérateurs les auteurs les autrices le
font et donc tout ouvrage qui nous
permet d'éclairer cette avenir qui
parfois en ce moment nous paraît un peu
en buée d'expression gentille
et donc sera distingué quelqu'un qui
aura écrit quelqu'un qui aura écrit un
livre de cette nature là faire du bien
nous faire parallèle
c'est quand même aujourd'hui une sac
d'entreprise donc ça c'est pour le prix
des visionnaires on a vu les auteurs et
les ouvrages sélectionnés si vous pouvez
nous présenter justement ces auteurs en
quelques mots qui sont-ils et pour quel
roman justement ont-ils été sélectionné
alors là moi j'ai pas le j'ai pas tous
les éléments pour pour faire la
présentation et je voudrais pas dire de
bêtises comme vous avez vu on s'est
installé dans cette vision de façon un
petit peu impromptue sur moi je suis pas
avec bon je suis même pas dans mon
bureau donc voyez je veux pas me
permettre
pour les préciser alors en lice GPS de
Lucie Rico il y a l'inventeur de Miguel
Bonnefoy et le dernier des sien de
Sybille grbbert donc ça c'est pour le
prix des visionnaires et donc je le
disais il y a un deuxième prix Daniel
picoulis c'est lire et choisir et alors
là la sélection a été opérée me semble
par les collégiens de 50 ans divine
c'est eux directement qui ont lu ces
ouvrages qui ont fait cette sélection
oui alors pour revenir au premier prix
faut quand même que que j'admettre que
le livre de Miguel Bonnefoy m'a
particulièrement touché c'est un auteur
que j'aime beaucoup ce qui ne préjugent
rien bien évidemment de la vie mais il y
a dans cette sélection-là en tout cas un
livre qui qui me va droit au cœur pour
les
7 jours formidable quand un jury n'est
pas un jury de spécialiste je participe
à beaucoup de jurys qui sont comme ça
des fois parité entre les écrivains ce
qui est formidable c'est que les
écrivains prennent une leçon parce que
les gens lisent et lisent très très bien
et prennent très à coeur leur rôle et je
peux vous assurer que dans ces jours là
on en revient des fois on revient avec
quelques certitudes et on prend même
pouvoir
non pas influencer mais faire avancer
son son avis on écoute et on s'aperçoit
que ces livres ont été très très très
sérieusement et ça nous arrive et très
souvent non pas de changer d'avis
de reconnaître la vie des autres
et donc on va peut-être pouvoir voir
cette sélection s'affiche également pour
ce prix à lire et choisir et tout comme
le prix des visionnaires il y a trois
livres également qui sont en compétition
vous retrouver aussi toutes les
informations sur le site Internet des
médiathèques de 50 ans en ligne beaucoup
d'animations aussi à au programme de
cette journée festive Daniel picouli on
va en terminer par là il y aura
notamment aussi pour clôturer la journée
votre one man show pompette qui est tiré
de votre roman Les larmes du vin en
quelques mots de quoi ça parle et
pourquoi l'avoir adaptée en spectacle
alors d'abord parce que j'avais déjà
adapté un texte en spectacle ça
s'appelle la faute d'orthographe et ma
langue maternelle j'avais donné à
Avignon et puis dans un théâtre parisien
que ça me manquait et la pompette c'est
une espèce d'évidence pompe voyez le
petit bonhomme sur sur cet affiche c'est
moi et je suis dans le ventre de ma
maman et ma maman
a envie de sortir
ma mère
m'envoie un petit coup d'abricoter un
petit alcool Suisse
[Musique]
de discussion vous avez appris beaucoup
de choses
qu'on les avait oublié donc j'ai voulu
essayer de refaire un petit tour du côté
de ma mémoire intra-utérine pour me
souvenir ce que j'entendais quand ma
maman était là et que j'étais dans son
ventre et que ça discutait un peu des
affaires du monde et beaucoup de moi
donc voilà c'est un peu cette idée là et
donc je vais raconter ma naissance et
mon baptême qui est pas mal bousculé
bien évidemment c'est un texte qui se
fait drôle parce que c'est quand même
drôle et amusant étonnant d'être dans le
membre de sa maman avec un petit coup
dans l'aile
[Musique]
tous les deux on partagera la vie comme
un chemin qui mène à rien comme une
longue mélodie
tous les deux on partagera la nuit comme
un festin qui manque de rien comme une
douce insomnie à la balle
[Musique]
moi pour ce premier single premier clip
aussi sorti en septembre dernier à tous
les deux qui parlent d'une histoire
manquée l'histoire d'un type qui
s'imagine vivre une belle rencontre la
plus belle de sa vie mais il va jamais
oser son approcher soit par timidité
soit paresse alors le tout sur un rythme
quand même entraînant pourquoi justement
ce thème et pourquoi le faire sur un
rythme entraînant parce qu'on parle
d'une histoire un peu triste finalement
dans la composition quand j'ai écrit
c'est moi qui écris les paroles et c'est
vrai que c'est faire un petit pied-né
par rapport à tout le cheminement de
l'histoire on pense vraiment que c'est
une superbe histoire d'amour ou tout
justement qui en tout cas parce que
prochainement il va y avoir alors
peut-être que je dévoile un petit peu
l'actualité mais sur les prochaines
sorties qui de prévu pour nous des
chansons justement peut-être plus plus
rigolotes d'accord
avec en tout cas avec moins lourdes on
va dire et qui qui parle justement un
peu bah voilà de tout ça de de ces de
ces de ses sentiments qu'on ressent au
quotidien alors vous êtes tous les deux
musiciens intervenants vous enseigner la
musique comment vous êtes rencontrés au
final comment ça comment sont nés les
mineurs bon travail
tous les deux au conservateur de
Rambouillet
et on travaille dans les écoles autour
de la communauté d'agglo de Rambo et
territoire et ça qu'on s'est rencontrés
au travail moi j'avais une compétence à
côté on cherchait du coup chercher un
musicien pour m'accompagner sur scène
pour les les spectacles et j'ai demandé
j'ai proposé à Bastien de nous rejoindre
parce qu'on s'entendait bien au travail
et en fait on a commencé à écrire une
chanson comme ça et en fin de compte ça
a vraiment bien marché donc août 2019
voilà donc c'était la première chanson
des mineurs et on s'est rendu compte que
le duo fonctionnait fonctionnait bien
qu'on avait une aisance pour écrire
c'est vrai que moi je cherchais enfin si
j'avais quelques on avait chacun un peu
des petits papiers de nos côtés des
bouts de carnet griffonnés et en fait on
s'est rendu compte qu'on avait
la confiance et la volonté de faire
quelque chose tous les deux c'est vrai
que le travail à deux peut être parfois
un peu compliqué mais vraiment que
chacun peut avoir son univers aussi
là qu'on avait vraiment deux univers
différents mais que justement le but
c'était vraiment de les mélanger donc à
chaque fois on est dans des formes on se
prend un peu la date mais toujours dans
une idée commune et c'est ça qui est
très intéressante je suis sûr que
Véronique se pose cette question
pourquoi les mineurs
non il y a plein de majorité ce mot là
parce que il y a il y a plein de il y a
plein de choses derrière premièrement
parce que voilà je suis moi moi j'ai la
famille lorraine j'ai tous
cette imaginaire là en tout cas qui qui
est très fort pour moi qui définit un
peu la poésie qu'on fait c'est à dire
qu'on prend vraiment des choses du
quotidien des fois des choses qui sont
pas forcément très joyeux des moments
difficiles de la vie et on essaye d'en
dégager dans une poésie et ça que toute
la poésie de Germinal tout ce qui se
passe avec cette cette poésie ouvrière
nous intéresse beaucoup dans ce dans
cette dans ce travail pour les poétique
on a aussi mal travaillé acoustique avec
les instruments en bois avec le bois des
instruments le métal de la trompette
donc avoir vraiment quelque chose de
très
artisanal artisans du son aussi qui nous
plaisait justement on utilise voilà des
des instruments réels ce qui est
peut-être un contresens ce qui est un
contresens par rapport à beaucoup de
musique actuellement et ce qui est très
bien d'ailleurs c'est pas une critique
mais nous pouvons utiliser beaucoup de
santé beaucoup de son de sample de son
déjà enregistré on essaie de faire nous
justement des le plus de son bah du truc
de travail instrumental en fait et du
coup ce côté voilà ouvrier du son
artisan nous plaisait bien quoi et pour
l'autre histoire aussi c'est qu'au
départ toutes nos chansons étaient en
mineur et le mode mineur en musique
c'est le mode un peu voilà et c'est un
mode un mode qui est plus sombre on va
dire quand dans les couleurs de la
musique et bah c'est un copain qui est
venu nous voir mais en fait de toutes
vos chansons elles sont mineures et ça
nous a tout de suite ça résonné et on se
dit ah ouais c'est le nom du groupe et
on va on va se nommer comme ça et on n'a
jamais on n'a jamais changé jamais
hésité on a su que c'était ça et le
mystère et on a vu donc quelques images
du du clip qui est sorti en septembre
c'est un premier clip c'est différent de
travailler sur l'image aussi alors il y
a un projet musical pour la première
fois un clip qu'est-ce que ça fait
travailler sur un clip qu'est-ce que ça
vous a fait qui est réalisé par Nicolas
Thomas je le précise bah c'est compliqué
parce que en fait avec bastion on fait
vraiment tout nous-mêmes on en
auto-production on a notre propre label
on
c'est un peu nous qui descendu c'est
beaucoup de travail mais finalement tous
les projets à la fin sont sont comme on
les a voulu c'est vrai que sur le clip
on a rencontré du coup Nicolas et on
arrive avec nos idées en tête il me dit
ok bon maintenant on va faire quelque
chose de réalisable mais voilà c'est un
travail on savait qu'on était pas du
tout spécialisation on a fait
complètement confiance à Nicolas il nous
a apporté ses visions nous on a aussi
expertise son expertise et c'est vrai
qu'on a réussi à arriver à un projet qui
pour nous correspond tout à fait à ce
qu'on avait au départ même si ça a
beaucoup changé par rapport à notre idée
et toutes les personnes qui ont
participé à la réalisation de ce clip
que ce soit bah au cadrage Lucille ou
Thomas pour la régie et le montage et
même tous les figurants les musiciens
qui ont participé on était tous enfin il
y avait une volonté commune de bien
faire et je crois qu'on était tous
d'accord sur l'idée finale du clip et ce
qui fait qu'en fait ça a été un plaisir
de travailler ça s'est tourné en deux
jours deux jours et demi
ce qui est assez compliqué parce que
entre des problèmes de météo on voit que
clip est contourner en extérieur enfin
on a réussi à voilà il y a eu des
convergences les planètes étaient
alignées on était tous d'accord en fait
tous en dans la direction
et du coup alors premier clip première
single pardon il y avait eu aussi un
premier EP il me semble en juillet 2021
création du groupe en 2019 quel est
l'objectif maintenant du coup vous avez
commencé à en parler les prochains
projets mais quel est l'objectif pour
les mineurs on va continuer avec un
premier il y a un album qui se prépare
première album qui sort Mimet voilà on a
pas encore la date précise mais en tout
cas on est sur les sur le Tour de mi-mai
voilà l'album qui s'appelle les hommes
de muridan en hommage à cette petite en
référence à cette petite histoire de
Spinoza enfin de la neburydants qui se
retrouve à la croisée de deux chemins
qui me dis je sais pas quoi choisir et
nous on est un peu là-dedans maintenant
avec avec Bastien c'est pas qu'on va pas
choisir le chemin mais en tout cas on
arrive à un premier album qui
l'aboutissement du travail vraiment de
notre premier travail ensemble et
maintenant on va voir la suite la suite
on verra quel chemin prendre avec une
promesse des chansons plus joyeuse
contraindre en influence donc vous allez
avoir de la chanson vraiment un peu
franchouillarde même si c'est voilà la
chanson qui s'inspire des années 50 il y
a de la chanson un peu plus rock on va
voir beaucoup de styles différents on
avait déjà avec avec tous les deux il y
a aussi notre deuxième single qui est
sorti en janvier qui est beaucoup plus
un peu plus urbain un peu plus presque
rap donc on essaie vraiment d'aller voir
plein d'univers différents de tester
plein de choses et c'est un vrai plaisir
de d'aller voir tout ça en tout cas pour
le premier album on a hâte de vous le
présenter ça fait un an et demi qu'on
travaille dessus donc
Bastien est-ce qu'il y a des des
prochaines dates sur lesquelles on
pourra vous entendre tout à fait alors
on va prendre les dates dans le 78 il y
a le 8 avril au court-bouillon à
Rambouillet c'est un café associatif qui
est ouvert il y a un an un an et demi je
crois donc ce sera notre première date
avec un batteur parce donc là on est
deux actuellement et on a décidé pour
pour l'esthétique de pour la suite des
événements pour la suite des concerts de
de travailler avec un batteur donc c'est
pareil encore une fois une remise en
question on revoit les arrangements on
revoit comment on fait les morceaux sur
scène c'est une autre manière de jouer
et
de la musique le 24 juin pardon on fait
aussi le 25 mai au polo pub à
Rambouillet encore une fois on a une
super date à la maison Elsa Triolet
Aragon qui on est en partenariat pour
travailler justement sur les textes
d'Aragon avec des enfants donc les
mineurs donc et donc on fait une super
date le 20 août dans un excellent cadre
et je pense qu'on retrouve toutes ces
dates sur votre site internet c'est
exactement www.les mineurs.fr qui
s'affichent en bas de l'écran mais en
tout cas merci d'être venu parler de ce
projet autour de ce plateau les mineurs
à toute l'actualité bien sûr à retrouver
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran prête pour vos insolite
Véronique ça y est c'est à vous on
démarre avec les insolites
on va parler d'addiction aux réseaux
sociaux il me semble pour commencer un
phénomène qui touche tout le monde mais
surtout les jeunes moi en tout cas moi
ça peut me toucher je sais que quand
j'ai pas mon portable à côté de moi je
peux me sentir mal et pas avoir les
moments quelque chose à regarder un défi
qui est lancé par une association
pendant 10 jours pour débrancher les
jeunes des réseaux sociaux ça chatouille
alors ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas que
les réseaux sociaux sur les écrans
général parce que ça touche ils essaient
de toucher tous les âges des plus petits
jusqu'aux collégiens donc c'est une
association qui existe depuis 2017 à
Chatou elle s'appelle dix jours pour
voir autrement alors pourquoi 10 jours
pour voir autrement parce qu'en fait
c'est le temps nécessaire pour se
désintoxiquer des écrans d'après les
spécialistes voilà alors cette
association de de ces gens de Chatou qui
font partie de l'enseignement du monde
de l'enseignement des parents d'élèves
etc
propose à des à des jeunes à leur
famille à des plus petits de d'essayer
de réduire il y a pas d'interdit de
réduire la consommation d'écran pendant
10 jours et et alors du coup on leur
enlève ça mais on leur propose autre
chose à la place parce que ça ça laisse
un vide parce qu'en fait il faut savoir
que l'enfant petit il joue puis un âge
où il joue plus trop qu'est-ce qu'il
fait ben hop il prend un écran il oublie
qu'il aime dessiner il oublie qu'il aime
construire je sais pas quoi faire de la
poterie voilà donc en fait il faut leur
euh finalement oui puis les éléments et
leur proposer des activités
qui remplaceront donc l'écran de façon
bénéfique voilà donc bah ça marche très
bien ils ont des très bons retours il y
a par exemple ils ont proposé à
certaines enseignants de de donner tous
les soirs pendant 10 jours un petit top
bag à chaque enfant avec dedans une
petite activité à faire le soir mais
ludique évidemment alors même un truc
les règles du jeu de la bataille jouer
aux cartes je sais pas qui pour faire de
la pâte à sel faire des choses hyper
basiques qu'on fait on oublie il y a des
collégiens même qui disent bah oui
j'avais oublié que j'aimais dessiner
j'avais oublié que j'aimais jouer du
piano ou au piano du piano les musiciens
dieu merci voilà donc ça c'est
complètement gratuit donc pendant ces 10
jours
mieux vaut tard que jamais j'en parle
maintenant mais demain demain le 29 mars
ça va vous concerner aussi parce que ça
c'est Eric Desbois qui fait partie
l'association qui a un professeur de
jazz les portes sont ouvertes
conservatoires et il faut venir au
conservatoire de Château découvrir vous
allez peut-être me confirmer j'espère et
bien qu'il y a aussi des nouveaux
instruments il y a aussi de la zumba il
y a aussi je sais pas c'est dépoussiérer
vous êtes addict vous au smartphone ou
pas du tout
quand je vois que ça concerne pas que
les enfin on est encore jeune mais ça
concerne pas que les enfants tous les
lundis j'ai mon rapport hebdomadaire et
quand tu vois quand il me met que j'ai 4
heures 4h30 par jour d'écran en fait ça
me fait une petite ouais ça me fait une
petite blessure et puis après tu oublies
et puis on reprend
les écrans avaient joué dans la musique
pratiquer un sport en tout cas fait
autre chose aussi pour ça irait euh
agit toute l'année et propose il y a la
semaine de l'écriture en janvier au
secret des cartes de vœux le la journée
du jeu le 23 mai bon bah il faut
regarder sur leur site et surtout ils
sont complètement prêt à venir dans
votre école votre collège pour expliquer
leur travail expliquer comment faire et
s'aimer donner montrer l'exemple et voir
que ça marche et les jeunes même les
jeunes sont contents de de réaliser que
ils peuvent vivre sans écran et d'avoir
fait autre chose il y a une stimulation
entre eux quoi voilà une bonne nouvelle
à Rambouillet je sais que ça va vous
intéresser tout directement après la
fermeture du cinéma Vox c'est en 2019
les habitants vont pouvoir bénéficier de
nouveau de séances de cinéma exactement
c'est en la salle de spectacle à
lanterne qui on a donc dédié une salle
la salle Monique de Tilly un nom comme
ça bref vous la connaissez cette dame
merci et qui va donc servir de de cinéma
provisoire voilà et il y aura donc
demain
après être allé au Conservatoire voilà
vous pouvez aller au cinéma à
Rambouillet le 29 mars donc demain ça
sera la première séance et vous aurez
trois deux à trois séances par jour les
mercredis vendredi samedi dimanche les
films arriveront une semaine après les
sorties officielles les films resteront
15 jours à l'affiche le tarif c'est
vraiment pas cher c'est 4,50 à 8 euros
qu'à 50 c'est pour les moins de 14 ans
voilà pour les mineurs et puis ces deux
rues de la Légion d'honneur et quoi
d'autre alors ça sera aussi ouvert en
juillet en août mais pas en juin
pourquoi parce qu'en juin les assauts
ont besoin de la place pour leur gala
voilà
de nouvelles séances ouais une petite
réaction si vous voulez
retrouver sur le site de rembouiller
toute la programmation mais allez-y
quelques quelques exemples
alors je verrai toujours au visage de
janeiry vous avez aussi sur le chemin
noir avec Jean Dujardin donc on a déjà
parlé et le lion et les trois brigands
un
c'est de ma faute du côté de
vilaine-sur-seine heureusement que je
suis souple on va sauvegarder enfin en
tout cas on va tout faire pour
sauvegarder les
hérissons pour les sauver formidable qui
s'appelle vie comme vilaine initiative
et écologique voilà cette association
elle écrit en 2014 par une dizaine du
vilains une dizaine voilà et en fait ce
qui se passe et si vous avez un projet
écologique vous avez envie de mettre en
place à vilaine sur scène vous allez les
voir vous discutez avec eux ils vont
vous offrir un cadre pour mettre en
place votre action donc là Monsieur
Philippe Dupraz
est-ce que je vérifie si c'est bien ce
mot fil du Praz oui c'est bien souvent
fais-toi confiance fais-toi confiance ma
fille donc lui il a il en a eu marre de
voir tous ces petits animaux morts sur
les bords des routes et principalement
des hérissons donc il a grâce à lui il
va y avoir 12 panneaux attention au
ralentissez hérisson parce que les
hérissons sont
des animaux nocturnes se font énormément
écrabouiller et il faut savoir que c'est
le meilleur ami du jardinier c'est eux
qui vont manger vos limaces vos
escargots qui vont qui elle-même
eux-mêmes dévore vos salades Grégory et
donc on a besoin du réseau alors ce qui
est assez rigolo c'est quand on regarde
sur internet je parle vite parce que je
sens qu'on est non
alors quand on regarde sur internet
cette histoire de
Hérisson à vilaines-sur-seine il y a un
espèce d'organes un organisme union
internet pour la conservation de la
nature qui dit oh là là pas de risque de
disparition de des hérissons animal
après occupation mineure en revanche les
fouines et les blaireaux eux sont en
voie de disparition alors ok on va
protéger les fouines et le bureau mais
en fait ce que m'a expliqué le monsieur
que j'ai eu au téléphone tout à l'heure
c'est que les hérissons dans certaines
régions sont en voie de disparition et
pas dans d'autres et puis on n'est pas
encore menacé d'invasion de Hérisson à
ce que je sache donc pourquoi pas les
protéger d'accord
si vous voulez organiser un potager en
permaculture chez vous enfin si vous
habitez sur ça bien évidemment ils vont
venir vous aider si vous n'avez pas de
jardin vous pouvez bénéficier du jardin
partagé
gnagnagna
j'ai oublié surtout de vous voir
allez-y allez-y très rapidement le
prochain projet c'est un écureuduc un
écureuduc
peut-être que ça sera au menu de votre
d'une prochaine chronique
entre deux arbres le long d'une rue une
route pour que les écureuils
passention sur les insolites c'est le
cinéma de
maintenant mais c'est le cinéma c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
manquait j'avais connu le box le cinéma
de locaux moi j'ai conduit à Élancourt
on avait le ciné 7 qui est toujours
ouverte mais du coup c'était génial
quand il y avait des alternatives
chouettes avec le cratère saint-arno et
mais c'est vrai que la plupart aussi des
grands films c'était fallait violer
jusqu'à Saint-Quentin c'est quelque
chose qui est dommage pour une ville qui
pourrait je pense que c'est une bonne
manière de dynamiser la ville en tout
cas et de Rambouillet merci Véronique
vous revenez à la semaine prochaine
insolites voilà c'est bientôt la fin de
ce 7 8 on va jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil aux prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
un ciel voilé demain pendant toute la
journée sur le territoire yvelinois côté
température dans la matinée c'est
similaire à aujourd'hui il fera 9 degrés
dans toutes les Yvelines et dans
l'après-midi en revanche c'est beaucoup
plus printanier voire estivale 19 degrés
sont attendus sur la moitié nord du
département il devrait faire 18 degrés
au sud aux alentours de Rambouillet ce
mercredi 29 mars c'est la sainte Gladys
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de
votre fidélité et on se retrouve dès
demain pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]